يتولى بوليس في ستوديوس وزاره الدفاع
الالمانيه في وقت حرج في المانيا وفقا
للوزير الجديد عليقه في خضم حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بجيش غير مجهز والجيش نفسه يواجه
مهمات صعبه يقول بيستوريوس في وقت تشارك
فيه المانيا بشكل غير مباشر في القتال
الدائري في اوكرانيا
ووزاره الداخليه في حكومه سكسونيا السفلى
ابتداءا من عام 2013 الا انه فشل في الفوز
برئاسه الحزب الاجتماعي الديمقراطيه عام
افتقاره في ستوريوس للتاثير الواسعي في
السياسه لا يعني انه لا يمتلك خبره واسعه
كما يقول اولاف شولدز فالرجل اثبت الجداره
في الاداره وشارك في وضع السياسات الامنيه
للسنوات عندما تولى وزاره الداخليه في
ساكسونيا وهو الشخص المناسب لقياده القوات
الالمانيه البوندسفير في عصر التغيير هذا
مع تمتعه بالقوه والهدوء الذي يحتاجه البر
في مثل هذه المهمه الكبيره بحسبس
يخلف كبار سبيستور يسال وزيره المستقيله
كريستاللامبراخ في وقت تتعرض فيه المانيا
لضغوط من دول حليفه لتسليم دبابات لابورد
الهجوميه المانيه الصنع
لمساعدتكيف في حربها ضد روسيا
فالحكومه الالمانيه لا يبدو انها تتجه
لارسال الدبابات الا حين تفعل واشطانيا
لم ينتهي بعد الى نتيجه
[موسيقى]